we're gonna have an impeachment trial  this is the only the third time in the  history of our country yeah that's crazy  yeah yeah it's we I'm learning I'm  catching up they're there all these fun  facts about sort of the the rules of  impeachment and and they're talking  about it on the news fun facts came out  today the Senate rules governing the  impeachment were created over 200 years  ago not amazing yeah partly they were  written by freshman senator bernie  sanders i don't think he was ever young  i think if you saw footage of him when  he was like 15 years old people look  into the world same guy  a lot of ceremony today Chief Justice  John Roberts and his members of the  Senate took an oath to remain completely  impartial during the impeachment trial  yeah then they all laughed for four  hours  [Applause]